nearly eight thousand people evacuated
from their homes this morning as dry
conditions fueled more than a dozen
wildfires in California a fire burning
north of Sacramento led to a state of
emergency in Santa Barbara County the
Widder fire has burned 7800 acres more
than 85 active wildfires are burning
across the West that includes at least
15 in California morale mirielle is in
Santa Barbara
good morning good morning you're looking
at the burnt-out shell of what used to
be a jeep it was left abandoned on the
side of the road and demolished by the
Whittier fire the roof up here is
completely caved in the tires down below
incinerated right here you can also see
there's glass it was melted to the hood
and there's these pieces of aluminum
just thrown everywhere this fire forced
3500 people from their home and this
road right here leads all the way up to
a campground where a daring rescue of
children took place there's no end in
sight for the Whittier fire which
started Saturday afternoon at the peak
of the weekend's heatwave when
temperatures hit a hundred and ten
degrees at least 20 structures have been
lost on both sides of the area's major
highway which is expected to remain
closed for days fires burning in an area
that hasn't burned in probably 60 years
this time-lapse video shows the fire
moving up a mountain peak until it
nearly reached a camera recording it
some 200 people were quickly evacuated
from campgrounds in the fires path in
addition to 80 children who were trapped
in a camp barracks Saturday incident
commander Mark Montello led the rescue
efforts the road to the camp was
compromised by fire on both sides oak
trees falling across the road
firefighters huddled with the children
for hours until it was safe enough to
transport them out of the cab and back
to their parents was there a moment that
you said
I'm really nervous about these kids so
it's you know it's a waiting game
right I was I was confident in our
firefighters to reach them wasn't
confident about the fact that we would
be able to get them out in a timely
manner this state is dealing with more
than a dozen fires about 36 miles
northeast of the Whittier fire the
so-called Alamo fire has charred at
least 24,000 acres and north of
Sacramento the wall fire is threatening
more than 5,000 structures more than
5,000 firefighters across the state are
battling fires they are sharing
resources at hoping that cooler
temperatures this week will help them
get the upper hand Nora let's hope so
Maria thank you so much